le droit de grève oui le droit de
bloquer les français non monsieur le
premier ministre
face à la crise sociale actuelle les
français en ont ras-le-bol ras-le-bol de
galérer en permanence pour pouvoir se
rendre à leur travail librement
ras-le-bol de voir chaque jour notre
nation se déchiraient un peu plus
ras-le-bol de voir que le service
minimum dans les transports est une
réalité partout en europe sauf en france
monsieur le premier ministre même si
certains syndicats ont une part de
responsabilité dans cette crise sociale
vous ne pouvez pas fuir la vôtre en tant
que chef du gouvernement
votre première responsabilité c'est
d'abord votre propre attitude celle qui
a consisté à entretenir le flou et la
confusion en brouillant les pistes
c'est l'échec de votre méthode qui
préfèrent les postures à l'exigence de
clarté les faux semblants au devoir de
vérité et chris cristallisent leur
angoisse depuis des mois c'est l'échec
d'un haut-commissaire censé incarner la
réforme est finalement obligé de
démissionner c'est l'échec de votre
double langage qui compte condamnera les
français à la double peine ils n'auront
ni la paix sociale immédiate ni le
sauvetage des retraites à long terme
le droit de grève oui la chienlit non
c'est avec une particulière gravité que
je me fais ici l'ambassadeur des
français de grande banlieue
il habite provins en gym orman verneuil
montereau moret ils sont sur la ligne p
ou r ils n'ont pas de service minimum 0
train des zones blanches sont rayés de
la carte
protégé par aucun statut aucun régimes
spéciaux ils doivent travailler pour
vivre tout simplement regarder leurs
visages
arras et vous comprendrez leur malheur
or vous avez une arme le droit de
réquisition ce n'est pas un problème
juridique
c'est un problème de volonté politique
madame la ministre
en ce 14e jour de grève contre la
réforme des retraites
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
commencent à publier leurs premières
statistiques qui mesure l'impact
économique de ce mouvement social sur
les commerces
les entreprises les pertes d'activités
déclaré par les professionnels sont
conséquentes et elles auront dans les
semaines et les mois à venir des
conséquences sociales avec
inévitablement son lot de sensations
d'activité de placements en chômage
partiel voire définitif selon le
quotidien le monde
le secrétariat général du gouvernement
sous votre autorité était informé dès
2017 de la situation de cumul des
mandats de votre ancien haut-commissaire
aux retraites
je rappelle que l'intéressé avait oublié
de mentionner dizaine de mandats publics
et privés non mentionnant que trois à
l'autorité après la démission de 12
ministres de votre gouvernement depuis
deux ans dont huit pour affaires où est
la transparence ou et l'exemplarité tous
les responsables politiques doivent en
être porteur au premier rang desquels
l'artisan du projet de réforme des
retraites
si important pour l'avenir des français
vous avez voté une loi en juillet 2017
pour la transparence et sans arrêt cette
loi est violée par votre gouvernement
pire c'est la constitution qui a été
bafouée l'hôpital public se meurt c'est
le cri de désespoir que 660 chefs de
service hospitaliers viennent de vous
lancer après le plan ma santé 2022 en
septembre 2018 nous en sommes au
quatrième plan en deux ans
ce n'est pas un plan de refondation du
système de santé mais seulement un plan
d'apaisement de la colère ce quatrième
plan ne résout rien monsieur premier
ministre quelles réponses allez-vous
faire au personnel hospitalier dans les
prochains jours il y a urgence défendre
aider le patrimoine en france est
devenue une urgence
et lorsqu'ils jouent au loto c'est avec
la conviction profonde que les sommes
qu'ils dépensent vont au patrimoine et
ne remplissent pas le puits sans fond de
bercy les députés rrm que stéphane bern
en colère a qualifié de technocrates
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est lui
l'assemblée nationale sous l'emprise de
bercy attendait a en effet annulé
l'exonération de taxe sur le loto du
patrimoine voté par le sénat
c'est méconnaître l'importance du
patrimoine facteur d'attractivité des
territoires de développement local et de
cohésion sociale
[Musique]